la remi questi cade perché scelto pietro
per fare che la mappa ma lo sai quanto è
difficile e quanto è complicato trovare
la strada giusta
the pen dire tantissimo io te lo dico
perché voglio che sia una sfida vera so
già che me ne pentirò tantissimo
buona visione ragazzi
[Musica]
grazie amico mio i ragazzi bevono di
questo video sono parigi oggi serata di
sport nice
oggi faremo un'altra mappa con il buon
pietro stiamo giocando ragazzi al
dungeon al prison escape alla presidente
cosa che succede succede che siamo in
una prigione questa volta siamo nella
prigione perché pietro commette i reati
ma dai ragazzi allora dobbiamo fuggire
dalla prigione e io vorrei capire un
attimo come si può fare a parte saltare
credo che sia abbastanza salti salti
sulla torcia e poi esce perfetto quindi
ragazzi spero che questo tizio piazzato
dietro la lasciamo là più di così non sa
fare ma questa era veramente una roba
già fatta cioè come fai non riuscì
allora usciamo usciamo poi ci sono anche
marie 50 classi ma ci sparano guardie e
ucciso
niente non puoi non puoi suoi guardi per
ripagare amico sito sito
ora che riguardi solo la minima
attenzione a non ci ha visti non ci ha
visti come fa bravo bravo bravo ottima
tattica bravissimo let's go no come
fatto riprendere la trave destra quelli
che facendo un po me la devo tirare in
testa ai detto no la trave l'idea la
nave di destra hai detto ho capito
adesso spettacolo santa su quella roba
lì a forma di gioco ligneo [ __ ] di
fornai
ecco ci diciamo vanta già fatta nava che
aveva per la porta per la porta poi non
si apre mai avviato una testata
fortissima fare un po di parkour
qualcuno che pensa sopra le travi credo
io sono caduto class che non ho capito
ma parco demonio porco a scusa arrivando
in là siamo sicuri che le guardie poi
non guardi in un altro e poi no perché
siamo in alto e noi siamo più furbi
guardia perché le guardi non si sa che
le guardi non guardano in alto guarda
attenzione molto bene allora l'acqua
bisogna scendere e poi bisogna saltare
sull'altra trave ok occhio o ma siamo
sicuri che non possiamo correre io
faccio le guardie picconatrice
nell'amore ma io potrei fatto tre anche
vederti mentre lo fai
guarda vai vai pure per me non è un
problema da che se ora accade ho sentito
che lo faccio anch'io la carità la
carità spesa che va bravo l'ha ucciso ma
scusami ma come com'è possibile ma solo
io non sono riuscito a passare st parti
ma scusami allora si può allora non un
cenone non è possibile in tre volte
dobbiamo capire come sfuggire c'è
chimica fatidica è facile amico c'è una
porta a porta è una voce che questa
porta qua era bellissimo è stato
altissimo barda ma davvero ma non ci
credo
piano piano piano caricare cose basta
andare alla carica
io ero venuto perché vi ho detto ci
crede come ci crede lui no è meglio di
no bene insiste ucciderlo un po prof
morto ucciso l'ho uccisa bravissimo si
può uscire è chiuso e vabbè tu cominci a
far fuori le guardiamo in coda c'è una
cinema il problema
a destra invece no ci ha provato la non
equa già sono una guardia e simpatica
però mai così male
beh c'era la porta grazie ciao ce l'ho
fatto miccoli fatto comitato mi hai
fatto venire alla fine viene alla fine
era però è una cagata perché devi vedere
una cosa che c'è ok ora passa in quello
di sinistra dice un blocco di legno
quando di quando scendi se vai avanti al
tc tu sei ok ora senza saltare tante
l'angolo
è vero corre corre corre vero che pirla
di sopra si ce l'ho fatta e vi erano
lunghissime iberico festeggiamo
picchiando sonoro smettila piano di
sopra
possiamo arrivare alle serre e la
prigione e segretissima perché le
persone non sono anche che siamo qua ma
c'è una finestra di terrore è bravo ma
adesso mi passate veramente sovrastare
sì sì ma dove sto picchiando alla scala
dal bravo non riesco a fare il parco
mura milito anche per sbaglio e ti ho
visto un uomo c'è altro buco l'ora in
una certa giusto qualcosa che cerchi
toci dove c'è qualcosa di rosso ha
saputo già la libertà amico allora
attenzione attenzione se chiudi la porta
cosa vi prego caridi bravo
prima bravo complimenti ridiamo qua
andiamo richiamo degli ai loro i
complimenti
che sfiga veri torneo di ragazzi
comunque abbiamo capito che stava già
assaporando la vittoria qui spuntano
questi maledizione ma ancora aperta la
fai a uscire ma non si passa da qua
forse no la porta perché ne so la
finestra fir la scelta finestra
io porto la foto sono 40 vanessa qua
ok arrivo che pirla via niente ma sei
scemo ma chiudi la porta ma così stupide
io non lo so io non so prima le signore
vada anche su una signora non importa ma
io lo sono morti sono guardie mamma l'ha
fatto da soffio mi piace la quadra
occhio dove dove è vero di qua o ci
andiamo oltre alla pistola 1 2 3 in casa
ma mi hai tolto qualcosa ridotto 60 tv
dovrebbe essere unito due hit rifacciamo
ok morto è morto è morto l'arte noi
scatta la finestra che ci ho fatto è
morto è morto bene e adesso che è morto
cosa bisogna fare il quale ai claiming
sulle librerie aveva prima volta lo fa
soprattutto per domandare se riuscito
come quasi di vedere sulla torcia di
quadri quadri quale aveva mai fatto da
torcere ha dato i soldi qui sotto no
questo è anche ha funzionato così non
rompere belushi soffitto rotto sì però e
dintorni che è no ma ce la fa ce la fai
anzi c'è un pezzettino che spunta qua
guardati come la fa così ma c'è un'altra
parte equa
seguimi 26 guardato capirla pure io c'è
uno spazietto era qui siamo usciti no
non è vero
quasi
ma è da vuole
volevo che c'entra si aspetta che anche
noi c'e la voglia faccio una guardia di
fare un po di gaming chiudi la porta
anzi non la porta
vedi così vedere i proci mi raccomando
sempre le porte aperte ma guarda in
questo momento lega serie b seguimi
veniva ora tutto quali carico perfetto
bene bravissimi il bambino mi sembra su
di te che palle non si dice così agli
animali è brutto sai che non so dove
devo andare di qua o di qua o non si può
fare
non si può fare vieni cayman o ma non si
può fare veramente vedere fatti vedere
certamente neanche lo si possa grande è
chiuso di far tipo con ancora la porta
come ho fatto tra sta roba perché prima
appunto l'ho visto però è ripreso
benissimo un dato di leo bravo più si fa
sì però non ho capito sei sicuro che sia
la strada giusta va e vieni dato
assolutamente no bravo lo sapevo che
c'era qualcuno io ha detto ma sei sicuro
che sembra di qua no ma c'è qualcosa
questo non muore lo reggo sono muore e
vero ho provato uscite non muore poi lo
aspetta c'è un'altra via tutto quanto è
sì si basa c'è un'altra via di qua sì
l'ho trovata dov'è lo trovate a 23 il
rapporto non c'era non vieni via ieri no
non l'ho mai gli era valso la bandiera
ce l'ho fatta amico ce l'ha fatta ce
l'ho fatta ci sono delle foto l'ex si
ferma ok bravo bravo bravo
siamo detto tali spies che poi non avete
visto niente
ma qui c'è un priming sulla porta 9
molto divisi questa quanto lunga st
prigione di alcatraz 5 di nome lista una
prigione così grossa vieni vieni vieni
amico sento odore di libertà
un tipo che nostro centro falisco c.da
non riesco a cederlo
apri e non muore sta ferma ma basta
fermo quindi sarà questa sarà solo un
oggetto non è vero ma che figata figo
questo trono il trono del castello
questo non subisce una finestra
ciao c'è l'uscita quale l'uscita o è
uscito siamo ancora la prigione aspetto
aspetta aspetta aspetta proprio la
famiglia scaletta maledizione manca
nulla e siamo fuori ricordiamo che ci
ricordiamoci che di lamento mentre ci
andrò
ok effetto butto giù di cuoio assistito
bravissimo però sta roba occhio cosa tue
foto
cos'è è dire troppo trovato l'ora tutte
le trappole quello delle trappole a il
pensatore trappolette no prendiamo le
cose facciamo dice facciamo le presone
presente le pretese e a sto punto di
andare altra parte
no no no non sprecano le ore voleva
uccidersi scusa non può uccidere questo
trappole e non lo so ci ha provato
pratica di strada è siamo stati
bravissimi ma questo era questa capacità
le trappole e vere con karama rossi se
c'è un modo per fare tranquillamente ce
l'ho fatta amico del cavolo
ora che il ghiaccio t'aiuta ragazzine
l'episodio termina qua perché abbiamo
già sfruttato tutti i nostri neuroni con
pietro sono pochi però sono contento
linz è arrivato fino qua ok fermiamo il
prossimo episodio la finiamo
teoricamente non si sa mai però si spera
quindi i ragazzi di semplice lasciate un
assetto commento mi piace servitori
piaciuti iscrivetevi al canale sono
stata prestiti e non ci vediamo
paga
[Musica]